le monde du transport aérien français
vit l'une de ces grèves sinon les plus
importantes du moins les plus
spectaculaires
on a joué au football aujourd'hui sur
les pistes de roissy
les boeing sont restés au sol version
syndicale de l'expression prendre son
mal en patience
à savoir une grève dure et un plan
social draconien ce mouvement a les
conséquences qu'on imagine
elles sont classiques vols annulés et
grogne des passagers louis carzou
semblait sur les pistes empêchant ainsi
les décollages comme les atterrissages
la rassemblement l'autre roissy charles
de gaulle avait ce mardi le visage des
mauvais jours
un visage qu'il risque des fichiers
encore cette semaine tant les échanges
syndicats-direction à air france
ressemble à un dialogue de sourds n'est
assez gaver des plans attal et on en est
au troisième ou quatrième
on avale et pas mal de suppressions
d'emplois y compris des licenciements
secs
aujourd'hui on nous en annonce 4000 de
plus et on nous annonce aussi beaucoup
c'est pour s'appeler jean droit s'ils
sont motivés qu'un 100 francs à 2000
peut-être 3000 francs de perte de
salaire mensuel nous allons maintenir ce
plan est dispensable pour la survie de
l'entreprise
mais nous discutons avec les
organisations syndicales avec les
partenaires sociaux de l'entreprise
ainsi à nombre de mesures
d'accompagnement notamment au bénéfice
des catégories aux salaires les moins
élevés des assurances qui ne semblent
pas avoir portés pour l'instant les
syndicats d'air france ont déjà annoncé
leur intention de poursuivre le blocage
des pistes demain à orly comme à roissy
quant au passage il ne leur reste plus
qu'à rejoindre un aéroport de province
ou bien sûr patienter voilà il y avait
que le précédent plan social c'est au
total jusqu'à la fin 1994 près de dix
mille suppressions d'emplois qui rompent
eu lieu à air france